absolutely in the uh right place for
this uh subject tonight uh we are
talking as you know about immigration
and what better place than uh an
institution which celebrates Britain's
place in the world and looks outward at
the Royal geographical society and and I
promise you we and the organizer the
debate played no hand in this absolutely
the right time for this debate you'll
know if you woke up to to uh the today
program this morning hearing Theresa May
announcing plans to make Britain in her
words a really hostile environment for
illegal immigrants uh announcing her
plans for a series of steps that will
make life hard for people who are here
illegally uh in terms of uh getting
access to health care or uh require or
being issued with his driver's license
or even opening a new bank account so
immigration dominating the news just as
we uh gather and at the if you flipped
over the newspapers that was what was on
the front page and on the back pages
Jack Wilshire of Arsenal leading off his
own debate on the nature of englishness
uh when he said that it wouldn't be
right for new players who had only been
here for two or three years from abroad
to be naturalized and then have a place
in the England football team he said it
should be uh England for the English uh
prompting a reply from Kevin Peterson
who pointed out that he along with
Andrew Strauss and Jonathan Trot and
Matt prior and several other members of
the England cricket team didn't hail
from these parts which reminded me of
the of the joke that was said when
England toured South Africa which is
where did the England team stay when
they tour South Africa answer with their
parents um so at both ends of the
spectrum either on the front pages or
the back pages immigration and the
issues that arise from it are very much
in our minds so it's the right place the
right time time and absolutely the right
people arrayed before you here this
panel wearing these microphone devices
that make them slightly look as if they
are the cast of The Book of Mormon um
this is because these are very Natty
state-of-the-art microphones rather than
some sort of facial disfigurement so
please do uh look past that um we're
going to get underway very very soon I'm
just going to give you a few notes about
how we do it uh as you know it's a
formal debate so opening speeches of
eight or nine minutes each from the
speakers when they're getting close to
time I will Ting and ping my glass by a
system of pre-arranged coded signals and
they will uh then stop uh we will hear
from all of them then we open it for
questions and contributions and I put
the emphasis really on questions uh from
the floor I will make sure that both
both uh upper and lower levels uh Ian
don't mean in terms of quality I mean in
terms of seating uh will contribute but
do keep them short and pointed because
we want to have as much time as we can
to get as many voices in as we can and
to hear from our speakers here so let's
get straight under way I know you voted
on your way here uh a preliminary vote
and I'm going to give you the results of
that uh after we've heard from our
speakers and of course you will then
have a chance to vote again the proper
vote the casting vote uh with this
little card for you put the tear off the
card for if you're voting for tear off
the card against if you're voting
against it is really like rocket science
it's terribly complicated I will explain
it again later um don't worry about that
so the motion before us is let them come
we have nothing to fear from high levels
of immigration uh to open uh the uh case
for the motion our first speaker is an
economist formerly at the treasury and
the European commission and now chairs
one of the most remarkable uh museums in
London the first Museum of immigration
in all of Europe at 19 princelet Street
please welcome our first Speaker for the
motion Susie
Sims
[Applause]
hello migration is innate in human
beings it's what brings us together but
immigration seems to be dividing us it
divides poor countries from rich
countries it divides even rich countries
from each other as in this background of
this motion pitching Britain against
Bulgaria and Romania it divides people
into us and them into who is native
who's an immigrant you know that's a
surprisingly old question go back 2,000
years and we find tacitus the Roman
historian wondering who the Britain are
he says well are they natives or
immigrants that's open to question then
he says well it doesn't really matter we
have to remember we're dealing with
barbarians now today of course we know
who's a native and who's an immigrant
except of course we don't because public
perceptions are way off the polling
organization IPOs Mori recently
discovered that people think
31% of the population are foreign born
in fact of course the true figure is 13
% and that's really pretty typical for
any successful wealthy country so
immigrations become or perceive to be a
really big issue and when we talk about
it we talk about facts and figures we
rarely talk about migrants themselves as
human beings so I was really excited on
my way here this morning this evening
when I um I saw this huge migrant
Memorial just across the road you must
have noticed when you came in the Albert
Memorial and there's there's Prince
Albert on his throne facing those
amazing museums that he created facing
the Albert Hall The Village Hall of our
nation these are symbols of Britain and
they're symbols of britishness and they
wouldn't exist were it not for that
migrant and they show so much cultural
Innovation the fusion of Sciences and
arts in this case diversity of Outlook
engineering Innovation even Financial
innovation of course not every migrant
is Prince Albert not every migrant is a
good migrant some migrants are lazy or
cheats but the story
exemplifies what migrants typically
bring because they bring energy and
flexibility and new ideas they develop
new things they modernized institutions
that actually often felt very
uncomfortable at the time but we now
treasure they do bring foreign ways and
some of them are ways we don't accept
some of them are ways that merge with
older traditions and become British by
adoption well like Prince Albert's
Christmas trees or by
Fusion I'm not saying that migration is
all good of course there have been
problems problems of integration and
David goodhart's written a lot about
them David may have overstated the case
a little but um I'll be clear I accept
there are problems of adjustment and
there are problems that have suspected
some native British communities but I
want to focus on where we have clear
evidence and we have archaeological
evidence we have DNA evidence we have a
wealth of economic evidence and despite
all the old jokes about laying
economists end to end and they never
reach a conclusion economists actually
agree on the economic evidence around
immigration so what do we know we know
immigration isn't new the people who say
that the British were a homogeneous
group of people for hundreds of years
until the postwar arrivals well they're
just wrong so Barry Kliff one of our
greatest living archaeologists concluded
we have always been a Mongrel race and
we are stronger for it we know that
immigrants don't take British jobs in
fact they tend to make jobs just think
about what happened at times of mass
immigration America in the late 19th
century Britain in the
1960s we didn't see jobs being lost for
natives we saw a growth in jobs overall
and there's overwhelming research on
Britain now immigrants working in jobs
here in Britain have little or no impact
on the employment of Natives and that is
just as true for unskilled migrants as
is as it is for skilled ones if you care
about unemployed unskilled young people
and I know how passionate haret is about
this then the answer is to do something
about their situation don't stop
unskilled migration which will change
nothing now I know there's a presumption
that if you're a pr- migration person
you're coming from a liberal left
perspective but my formative years were
spent working in a t treasury for a
formidable Tory Chancellor Nigel Lawson
and I learned pretty sharpish that
markets do a pretty good job and if you
want to let the state meddle in free
markets then you need some very strong
evidence
indeed but in fact of course curbing
unskilled migration is just much more
likely to make matters worse over time
as British firms employ more people
obviously those people earn money and
they want to spend the money and as they
spend it on goods and services more
people are needed to produce those goods
and services and more more jobs get
created and over time as migrants do
work alongside Natives and if we can
help our young people into be working in
jobs alongside new migrants then you get
a transfer of skills from migrants
transfer of attitudes even a work ethic
and that is one of the most important
things in the long term because that's
what raises productivity and raises
competitive competitiveness
and we know immigrants put more into the
economy than they take out the oecd
international organization authoritative
recently estimated that immigrants put
around 7 billion more into the UK
economy than they take out so don't fear
immigration on economic grounds
immigrants don't take native jobs they
tend to make jobs immigrants and net
contributors to the public CSE in fact
they put more back in than native
workers do and immigrants are not
sponges as we leared just yesterday the
government can't actually provide any
evidence of benefit tourism or health
tourism not on any significant
scale now I've been a migrant worker
myself and I came home like so many
migrant workers do bringing new skills
and attitudes it's actually back with me
but I came home because I like this
country I want to live here but I want
to live in Britain that's a strong
economy I want to live in a Britain that
can more easily afford the things that
we all want whether it's looking after
our elderly or educating all our young
people into work I want a Britain that
stays in the world rich list actually
and that's got money to do good in this
world and that means staying open to
migrants it means recognizing immigrants
are assets and not liabilities ask
yourself where will all these ambitious
flexible hard workers go if we keep them
out well they're going to go to China to
America to Germany to our competitors so
let them come here if we don't we shoot
ourselves in the foot we lose the
economic benefits of new new jobs higher
skills more growth more resources to
spend and then we smartly shoot
ourselves in the other foot by sending
migrants away to help our competitors so
don't just let them come welcome
[Applause]
them wait for
speak thank you you Susie our next
speaker is going to be the first Speaker
against the motion he's the director of
the think tank demos and the founder and
former editor of prospect magazine and
the author most recently of the British
dream a trenchant pmic on the subject of
immigration our first Speaker against
the motion David
[Applause]
goodart thank you very much Jonathan I
think it was a a calm analysis not of
pmic but um we'll leave that on one side
uh we all seem to be doing a bit of
crossdressing tonight um Susie was just
brandishing her Tory credentials well I
am what used to be called a Hamstead
liberal uh as Jonathan just said I run a
cental left Think Tank I started a
political magazine a liberal political
monthly magazine I'm a member of the
labor party I have two immigrant
grandfathers one Jewish I even live in
Islington so I am not against
immigration in itself only a trite is
against immigration in itself although I
did say this at a similar meeting uh
rather smaller meeting actually um a few
weeks ago and one of the fellow
panelists was Peter Hitchins who said I
am a trog actually um what really
separates us um on the two sides here is
one word the word
high if we replace the word high with
the word moderate all three of us would
be in favor of this motion what we're
skeptical about is the scale and speed
of recent immigration to this country
which has been quite historically
unprecedented 4 million net immigration
of 4 million over over four over over 15
years including many many years of gross
inflows of 600,000 people
600,000 people now I think that has had
on balance negative effects economically
culturally and socially and indeed on
balanced Global
development as on on the economy first
as Susie
said immigrants contribute to Innovation
uh We've we've got a great record of
Jewish East African Asian and other
groups creating um great entrepreneurial
initiative they fill skill gaps they do
dirty jobs that uh locals don't want to
do at least at the uh wages on offer um
but they do not at this scale improve
the economic well-being of the average
citizen that is pretty clear and
contrary to what Susie says actually
what all the academic economics on
immigration says is that it's remarkably
neutral in its effect on all the main
kinds of indicators growth wages
employment and so on um nonetheless it
is also pretty well accepted that it's
Mar it's beneficial for better off
people for employers and it's less
beneficial for people in the bottom half
or third particularly of the labor
market Market we have 20% of people uh
in in low skill people in Britain are
born abroad that is bound to have
downward pressure on wages and there's
plenty of evidence of the fact that it
does of course many people that come
here are complimentary to existing
workers um but there is obviously
displacement to there is clearly
displacement at the at the bottom ends
we created 2.7 million new jobs between
1995 and 20 2010 2.1 million were taken
by people born outside this country now
it's not it's not it's not as simple in
a way as that sounds but clearly there
has been some displacement and it and
this whole question is very different at
times when unemployment is High I mean
when when when you have full employment
as we did in the 60s then it's a very
different kind of story and I do worry
that we are warehousing too many of our
own weakest performers in the labor
market and we are in you know inviting
ing in often much more highly motivated
people from Eastern Europe the Latvian
graduate you know with a with a lower
wage demand and a higher work ethic and
it's a form of unfair competition on our
hoodies
um and and this damages the social
contract in Britain um you know which is
a which is a pretty serious matter for
all of us um on on fiscal things Susie
talked about fiscal things it's true
some groups particularly East Europeans
they they they come after they've been
educated and they go often before they
they're so they're here for the
you know for a few years of their
working life they tend to that they tend
to pay in more than they take out
although if you add in tax credits
people argue about it's not a huge
amount um but we also import have
imported over recent decades you know
multigenerational poverty I mean the
overall picture is not at all clear on
the fiscal side but just to conclude on
the economics what large scale
immigration does I think is exacerbates
some of the worst habits of the British
economy the short-termism the failure to
train uh the the lack of investment um
all of which is exacerbated now
immigration isn't just about economics
obviously economic data it's about
people both the people that come here
and the people that are already here and
clearly to most people in this country
or to to to many people in this country
anyway the numbers have been
unsettlingly high in recent years people
do value and quite reasonably enough
continuity familiarity stability in
their living arrangements the left used
to understand this you remember Michael
Young in the 1950s writing passionately
about the way in which workingclass
communities were inantly moved from from
one area to another uh without taking
into account patterns of life and so on
we saw this with uh the destruction of
mining communities in the 1980s the left
seemed to understand the you know the
human need for for settled patterns of
Life there was even a marvelous in The
Observer the other day from Ed valum
talking about Notting Hill and how the
old Notting Hill Middle Class had been
discombobulated by the new super rich
who were coming in and building swimming
pools in their basement and so on um I
mean just a few a few stats on the
degree of change that that I'm talking
about in 10 London Burrows that's 10 out
of 33 London Burrows more than half of
the population changes every 5 years
more than half of the population that's
an extraordinary degree of churn and
it's only slightly lower levels in some
of our other big
cities integration has been very
successful in some places and very
unsuccessful in other places let me just
give you one statistic which which sums
up the the relative lack of success in
some places um in a study of the 2011
census by the academic Eric calman he
looked at he did a w analysis of the
2011 census he discovered that
45% of minority Britain ethnic minority
Britain lived in wards where 45
sorry it was 45% who lived in WS where
um less than half of the population was
white British in some cases a lot less
than half was white British now that
number was only 25% in 2001 so you can
sort of see the degree of concentration
in some places in other places there's
been dispersal and and happily mixed
communities but it's not everywhere and
speed and scale helps to create that if
too many people come in too quickly it
becomes you know countries like
communities have absorptive capacities
which I think people on the other side
often don't grasp um at Prospect
magazine we did an interview with with
uh with Ken who's on the other side in
2007 and we talked about when would
London go majority minority and he said
probably not in in our lifetimes in fact
as we were speaking it probably already
was majority minority as you know from
the 2011 census London is now 45% white
British having been 60% white British in
2001 one you're you're seeing huge
movements in the outer Burrows places
like barking and dagenham 40,000 white
British people left between 2011 2001
and and
2011 that this causes a kind of
hunkering down in in the population if
people if it happens too quickly if
people don't have the time to to create
connections across ethnic and other
boundaries then they withdraw from the
public space Robert putam the American
political
scientist who's a great liberal and he
didn't like his own findings but he
found in America that that there was
this phenomenon of hunkering down so
people even in their own communities
become more aranged from each other in
areas of great uh rapid change and
fragmentation and I think in the
long-term survival of of of welfare
states and and decent polities um uh
requires a degree of of of common norms
and and cross-ethnic and cross-class
communication uh that is put in Jeopardy
by these kinds of changes my final area
is this the this idea of global
balance now if you take the brightest
and the best the most ambitious and best
educated people from poor countries it
is bound to hamper their
development um as with immigration into
countries like ours at modal moderate
levels and particularly people go back
after they've got an education or
they've had some experience of working
here it can be enormously mutually
beneficial but as the development
Economist Paul ker who some of you will
know he's the author of the book The
Bottom billion he spent his entire
career worrying about the welfare of the
poorest people in the world he has he
has turned against the consensus amongst
development economists and now argues
that it is indeed against the interests
of poor countries to send their best
people in our Direction um my final
Point much of the benefit that Susie was
talking about I agree with too but the
point is we could have those benefits in
this country with net immigration of
880,000 that would still mean gross
inflows of about 300,000 that's hardly a
closed society and I think we could we
could have all the Stu International
students the refugees the highly skilled
people that we want so I think you
should vote against this motion you're
not a bad person if you do so nor do you
have to be a supporter of ukip
and with all um with all due regard to
to Nigel I want to be tough t on ukip's
populism but also tough on the causes of
populism from the other side of this
debate thank you very
[Applause]
much thank you uh to David goodart our
next speaker and our second speaker for
the motion is a political Legend in this
city he served as the mayor of London
until the voters deci decided he should
spend more time with his NES uh during
that time as mayor of London he promoted
the city as a place of internationalism
and multiculturalism he is of course our
second speaker for the motion please
welcome Ken Livingston thanks let
me
he Jews bring Crime and disease to
Britain now who wants to guess which
paper that that was a headline in it was
of course the daily M I'd love to be
able to tell you that it was one of the
earliest stories by a cub reporter Paul
daker but it actually goes back to
1906 and I can't remember a time in my
lifetime when there hasn't been one
group or other being demonized by the
wring media I grew up in a London after
the war where the Irish were ridiculed
and looked down upon the first influx of
Caribbean immigration it was a big
political issue and of course we had
Enoch power on his rivers of blood
speech which didn't quite turn out as he
predicted and more recently of course
it's been Muslims and the male and the
express of working up to January the 1st
when it'll be Romanians and bulgarians
it's been a great way to sell papers and
a great way for unprincipled politicians
to Pander to Prejudice and get votes on
the on the back of it but the simple
fact is London which has had a greater
influx of immigration than I imagine and
a more diverse range of immigrants than
any other city in the Western
World London is the only city in Europe
that matches American levels of
productivity and competitiveness we are
20% ahead of the next city we are twice
the European average and so yes
immigration brings problems
of adjustment and accommodation but it's
brought a level of benefit which has
helped to fuel a The Rebirth of London
London was a declining City when I was
born I well just before the war started
the the the population was 8 and a half
million by the time we got to the mid
80s it was down to 6 and half million
we're back to eight we're on our way to
n and it's the most amazing and dynamic
city to live in and it's the diversity
of that City that makes makes it so
wonderful now all of this has been a
against a background in which no
government has ever had a program to
deal with immigration it's just been
left to happen the debate simply has
been about how much we should restrict
it never been a program to help the
assimilation of immigrants I mean when I
was mayor you could go down to Tower
hamlets and see Bangladeshi women
queuing to try and get into the colleges
where they were able to learn English as
a second language and year by year by
year half of them turned away because
the the courses were full any government
worth its metal and of course I'm
denouncing all of them I would have
actually had the programs in place to
make certain that everybody arrived who
couldn't speak English should be
enrolled on a course so they could not
underfunding it and in a sense it wasn't
so much of a problem in in the immediate
postwar period up up till
1979 because we had an Economy based on
Full Employment and a full employment
system is one in which the welfare deal
is a lot lower than if you live with
permanent levels of unemployment between
one and 3 million and right the way
through that
period we were creating new homes for
people to live in I quite a bit of
dynamism in our economy I since 1979 of
course we've lived with a much lower
rate of growth of GDP much lower rate of
investment and a catastrophic decline in
housing so it's not that immigrants came
here and took our jobs and took our
homes we failed the political class of
all parties to build the homes for our
population and create the good Hightech
High skill high-paying jobs instead
we've seen a degradation to a low wage
econ economy and whole groups of people
left behind it's easy to then focus on
immigrants and say this is the problem
no it's a failure of political
leadership under labor and conservative
governments to put in place the
structures that would have made our
society much more successful just take
housing I mean in that period up until
1979 under labor and touring governments
we built between a quarter of a million
and 350,000 homes a year half to rent
local councils the other half div Vine
over this last 35 years that numbers
come down at the moment to just about
110,000 not actually building homes for
rent creating a huge housing crisis and
don't for one minute believe well
there's a real problem we're already
crowded where will you put those Homes
New York and Paris like London have 8
million citizens in New York and Paris
they're concentrated in half the space
that London has London is the least
densely populated major city in Europe
it's our failure to build when I was
mayor now I'm sure Boris has still got
the same figures we had available
Brownfield sites enough to build a third
of a million homes you could break the
back of our housing crisis with the
political will and Leadership to do it
and then on jobs Government after
government has seen our rate of
investment Decline and done damn all
about it hoping that the bankers could
lift us all up to a new noera and we'd
all benefit as they trickled down on the
rest of us or piss on us as most people
would have actually described it Germany
did better Germany maintained a much
larger manufacturing set sector made
certain that Banks were prioritizing
investment in their domestic economy not
speculating abroad the result they still
have a manufacturing sector that
provides jobs for workingclass men what
you also o had is it's only in the last
couple of three four years that China's
overtaken Germany as an exporter of
manufactured goods Germany still exports
manufactured goods to China I mean we
aren't lacking good jobs because
immigrants took them we're lacking good
jobs because successive governments
failed to make certain we had the levels
of investment that allow an economy to
grow and modernize level of investment
at the moment in Britain 14% of our GDP
in America 19% in France 20% in China
48% but they have much better control
over their Bankers over there I a much
more rigorous regime of discipline if
they get it wrong I mean that's the
failure whole areas as the docks Clos as
our manufacturing clothes were left to R
never the programs put in place for real
retraining and achieving that level
investment that could have actually um
created those jobs and those
opportunities with the result that yes
there has been a degree of resentment
particularly amongst workingclass
communities who seen the quality of
their life diminished within the
lifetime and well in the last 30 or 40
years and under all governments not
making a party political point about
this so what do we do about this I think
we got to actually accept that yes
immigration is tremendous boost
particularly in a world that's now
completely Global if you go back to the
collapse of the Soviet Union the world
before in the world now is totally
transformed the level of international
trade the level of movement of peoples
and no one is going to be able to take
us back to the past that's the reality
of it we live in the global world if you
want to wct barriers you will wither
behind them just as the Soviet Union's
economy withered behind the barriers it
erected between itself and the rest of
the World Market what we've got to do is
tackle those got to build the homes so
that the homes are there for people that
need them at a price that they can
afford and that means letting councils
build to rent we've got to get the
levels of investment up tell our Bankers
don't spend all your time speculating
internationally I mean in Germany they
have Regional Banks Banks invest in
rebuilding their Regional economies and
that's the reality if we are prepared to
put in place the programs there is no
problem with immigration it's the favor
of politicians that have allowed
problems and it it was clearly a
catastrophe error of judgment for the
last Labor government to take the advice
of its civil servants that once a the
barriers to internal EU migration came
down and all the new accession nations
from Eastern Europe could come here that
only be 10,000 people come they got it
out by about 20 times and nothing was
put in place for that and of course in
London you had a lot of people oh we can
get a plumber at last do you remember
that line I I get a plumber for years
but of course in many other areas of the
country agricultural wages were
depressed because people could be
employed who were prepared to work for
Less you've got to make certain that if
we're having an open immigration policy
and I believe we should you've got to
put in place the housing and investment
and wage um policies um to actually deal
with that I don't want to live in a
low-wage economy I want my children and
grandchildren to grow up in an economy
that's up there competing and investing
and innovating with the rest of the
world and if you put barriers to
international migration we will slowly
wither and we will decline thank you
very
[Applause]
much thank
you our second speaker against the
motion is a journalist an author and a
research fellow at the right leaning
Think Tank the center for policy studies
she's also the author of a really
unusual and very good book which I must
recommend to you called among the hoods
my years with a teenage
gang nothing to laugh at there that's
the title of the book um the author of
that book and our second speaker against
the motion Harriet
Sergeant so let them come we have
nothing to fear from high levels of
immigration well who is this
we if it's me immigration is
great we middle classes are can now
afford services that were previously out
of our reach take my
nails this morning I had a Vietnamese
manicure which cost me $10
if I'd gone to have an English manicure
it would have cost me 30
or4 but let me tell you another side to
this
Wii six years ago I did a report on why
black Caribbean and white workingclass
boys are
failing I met Dave he's was white he's
white he was then 23 and living on
benefits in Hai
ings he's was very bright but like a
third of boys on free School meals his
school had failed to teach him to read
and write
properly Dave didn't want to be on
benefits he wanted a job a home for he
had a girlfriend and a baby and he
wanted to take care of them but he is
only qualified for menial work and in
Hastings there's not very much of
that the week before he' applied for a
job as a dustman only to be told that
there are hundred other people had gone
for the same job so then he'd gone to an
agency but they said he had no chance
because I am English they only took
polls on their books polls he said to me
sadly do all the jobs around
here now is that a surprise when Poland
is in the top 10 of the oecd's literary
league and that the UK like poor Dave
doesn't even make it into the top
20 and Dave's case is not unique of the
two million jobs created under labor 80%
according to on figures which went to
foreign
Nationals poor State schooling and
immigration have taken away Dave's
future
so I get a cheap
manicure and Dave is rotting on
benefits
immigration is not about
race it's about
class you have a situation that is great
for us we are not up against polls who
want our jobs or not
yet but it is disastrous for the very
people that I thought the left Were
Meant to
represent what does it say about the
craziness of our immigration system that
red
Ken is here standing up up for
well-educated and skilled immigrants and
that is left to me I mean for goodness
sake I write for the Daily
Mail it is left to me to stand up for
the poor and the
dispossessed let's look at another part
of this
we six years ago I befriended a South
London gang they and their families are
most reli on the
state it is them and not us who at the
mercy of our overcrowded hospitals
schools and
housing these young men are equally at
the mercy of our
prejudices the kind of prejudice that
David aronovich displays in his
column how many times have I been told
how many times have I read oh we need
immigration because our people just
won't
work
wrong
immigrants
work and my South London gang reject
work for the same
reason
money let me explain that with another
bit of this we the Swagger a black
cariban in his 20s and why he does not
work after I encouraged him he got a job
at Twickenham stadium in
Hospitality he loved it but he was a
little bit surprised that he was the
only English person there we soon
discovered why with his first pay
packet he was a third worse off on it
than when he was on
benefits which one of us would work
if we lost a third of our
income and then the Bays
came because he now had a job he had to
pay council tax but he didn't have the
money to pay council tax and I can tell
you all that the bays are very
frightening I know because I was there
when they came we had to escape by
climbing out of the kitchen
window work is a luxury he could not
afford for the polls that he was working
with it was a very different
story on the minimum wage here they as
he saw on a TV program can save and buy
a four-bedroom house with a nice Garden
back in Poland and even send their
children to polish private school
as Swagger said to me if the minimum
wage got me that in London and private
school for the kids I would be out there
working all
hours instead I get the BFFs kicking
down my front
door my final bit of this
we is sunshine another member of my
South London gang I be friend Ed and it
is the opportunities he lacks compared
to his
grandfather his grandfather had a
traditional education in Jamaica and
then came over as an immigrant uh to the
UK where he got um an excellent
four-year apprenticeship in a car
factory it set him up for a life he's
worked all his life he owns his own
home for his grandson it is a very
different story his grandson came out of
school with not nearly the the the level
of Education of his
grandfather and then when I tried to
find something for
Sunshine it it it was it was very
difficult I mean on the job
apprenticeships of that quality just
barely exist you have to pay for a
course which is can be anything from
£5,000 upwards and there's no guarantee
of a job at the end of it because why
would a firm go to the expense and
trouble of providing vocational training
when they can already get trained
Eastern Europeans off the
shelf Poland for example has excellent
vocational training but what is the
result instead of being a homeowner and
a taxpayer like his
grandfather Sunshine is on
benefits according to the London School
of Economics the cost of this Lost
Generation is 90 million pounds a
week so the we in this motion is these
young
men if we are answering this question
they have a lot to
fear Dave said to me I see men in their
40s who've been on benefits all their
life they spend their day taking drugs
and
drinking I don't blame them but it's too
early for
me I don't want to be beat like
that
unfortunately immigration a is beating
him so I urge
you to think of
sunshine and
Swagger and
Dave they are the
we vote against the
motion thank
you
our next speaker is the last speaker in
favor of the motion to remind you again
let them come we have nothing to fear
from high levels of immigration he is
the multiple award-winning columnist and
since this appears to be fashionable
these days uh a former member of the
Communist party uh we it's important a
columnist for the independent the
guardian the observer in the past and
now uh for the times please welcome as I
say the last week before the motion
David aronovich thank you
if I adopt a slightly peculiar stance I
have this sort of weird headset that
wasn't meant for somebody with a head as
fat as mine um and honestly I've had
urinary catheters that weren't as
tight really and actually we're
considerably more comfortable um in a
way it's odd that we on this side are
proposing the motion because according
to the the polling done by the
conservative Lord Ashcraft significant
polling is a uh a very big funer of good
political information about 177% of the
country and no more supports the
proposition of the motion uh about 60%
would support the opposition to the
motion in a way you've got to ask
yourself why it is that we are having to
propose a motion and the opposition and
not proposing instead their motion which
is that mass immigration has been bad
for Britain uh incidentally before we go
on um uh I wasn't aware that there was
such a thing as a Vietnamese manicure
and an English manicure uh I presume on
the Vietnamese manicure they give you
little pictures of hoochi Min on the
cuticles uh and so on or is the only
difference the price Harriet is it just
the price it's the price so it's only
the price the only price difference
between the Vietnamese manicure and the
English manicure is the price that's
begging the question why you didn't go
to the English one if you felt that
strongly about it but
nevertheless
what I'm saying is I think it would have
been much more difficult for the
opposition to be the proposition which
is to prove to you that mass migration
had been harmful we've already heard
that that the best case really that the
opposition can make is that the
economics are neutral they grudgingly
would admit that there is a significant
amount of benefit and yet we know that
the PO show that the vast majority of
British or large majority of British
people think that mass migration has
been harmful in other words they've
somehow absorbed a message that even the
opposition to this motion don't accept
um no no it's not just exactly David
precisely going to be my point and we
will get on to your notion about what
else it's about in a moment it's not
just about economics it's not primarily
about economics a lot of people think it
is but in fact it isn't because we can
agree that by and large at the very
least there has been some benefit to
migration and I think that Susie and Ken
and I would argue that the figures
actually show that there has been
significant benefit to this country from
Mass migration uh and significant
benefit in terms of innovation and also
in terms of that thing that it's strange
to find the right not believing in
anymore in terms of competition remember
competition if you face competition the
idea is you improve according to the
opposition of this motion these as have
understood them if you face competition
actually you give up that's actually the
model which we're supposed to which is
an unusual model to discover people on
the conservative side of the argument D
are actually supporting
nevertheless the
next the next thing that we can dispense
with are the things which are
essentially our myths about immigrants
which people believe which we know are
not true and which by and large the
opposition have not tried to Pedal to us
which is to their credit myth that uh
immigrants are more likely to claim
benefits and so on in fact there seems
to be a and this is not very surprising
because by and large the people who
migrate tend to be more motivated they
tend to be younger thus they help us out
with a demographic problem maybe in the
short term until we need new groups of
immigrants but nevertheless they do
because by being younger they're more
likely to be in the income tax bracket
and therefore to pay Taxation and
they're less likely to claim and indeed
that appears to be the pattern that they
put more back in than they take out and
they contribute more than uh than people
who are not migrants this is not an
excuse incidentally for deporting
non-migrants out of the country on the
basis of they don't contribute enough
although actually if you take David
goodhart's position that what we need to
reach is a situation of net migration of
80,000 one way in which you could ex get
to a net migration of 880,000 is by
deporting a few more people who are
already here and that would bring your
net clearer down to the figure which
just shows how ridiculous net migration
figures are one way or the other I mean
how utterly completely arbitrary and
absurd but as David says this is not
just
about economics nor is it about the myth
what you've discovered recently is that
far from being too dim and bringing the
educational level down which was what
used to be said about migrants they are
now too clever and as a result people
can't compete with them significantly
and so on and it just isn't fair instead
of being shers Etc and coming over here
for our National Health Service it turns
out that actually they don't Sher
anything like enough which
means which means that you get to the
appalling position whereby an employer
faced with an illiterate ex-gang member
on the one
hand and a poll on the other makes the
lazy decision to employ the poll whereas
according to Harriet's
notion if the poll weren't there at all
the employer would heartily and
immediately endorse the former
illiterate the illiterate former gang
member
well here's here's here's the question
no you can't here's the question would
you is that what you would do it isn't
which suggests that actually we want to
locate this problem somewhere else and I
hope to come to that before I finish my
speech so we next come to the if you
like the nub of David goodhart's
objection to mass migration um he says
it's a matter of the speed with which
it's happened and let's start first of
all by suggest by by remembering that
this of course is not about race you
used not to be allowed to talk about
immigration because you'd be called
racist now you can't suggest that
anybody who's opposed to immigration
does so partially because of race you're
got allowed to say it it gets people
extremely cross and yet when I turn to
David's own book I find a section right
at the beginning about the speed not
with which there are a number of
migrants into this country but the speed
and he referred to it with which we are
going
black um a Dem this is a demographic
Revolution says David uh why is it a
demographic Revolution because according
to the on since of 2011 the population
of England Wales that was not white
British in 2011 was a fraction under 20%
but by the time of the next census in
2021 the visible minority population the
visible minority presumably being David
people who don't look like most of us
look yeah people of non European
background as the visible minority will
have risen from 14% today to around 20%
for England and Wales and a few years
later for the whole of the United
Kingdom that means says David the
visible minority proportion of the
population including people of mixed
backgrounds will have trebled in just 25
years to which my immediate reaction is
so what so what if they have those would
include for instance my mixed race
nephew and my two n mixed race sons of
and Daughters of my other nephews and so
on and presumably that will also go for
a large number of people a number of
people in this room as well uh uh it is
hard for me to see this as being itself
a problem but David then goes on London
remains around 57% white including
non-british whites and 40 3% visible
minority but we'll also certainly almost
certainly be minority Vis majority
visible minority majority visible
minority by the time of the next census
and he says if Britain had a clear and
confident sense of itself that wouldn't
be a problem but since it doesn't then
it actually is uh in other words the
problem here is the speed with which
we're turn turning black if we could
just turn black a little bit more slowly
then in fact we would like it better and
yet this is not a conversation about
race uh it is of course partially not
entirely but partially a conversation
about race but as the conversation about
as the discussion about vocational
training proves it is actually about
something else as well today we've seen
the bringing in uh and the introduction
and the publishing of of the immigration
bill now the interesting thing about the
immigration bill is it seeks to solve a
problem we don't have I.E that there are
a lots of immigrants using our services
uh uh beyond what other people do it
also tries to tackle the problem of
illegal immigration by making people
like landlords and hospitals Etc check
people's status before they take them on
and incidentally I do hope you were
asked about yours before you came in
this evening I really do I wouldn't like
to think that there were any illegal
immigrants taking places in this Hall
away from perfect legal I think we
should all do our bit I really do to
make sure that none of them get in any
illegal immigrants here put your hands
up out go off go ridiculous um but it
isn't really about that it's a cynical
bill it's a cynical bill because
actually the very people it's Target at
don't believe it will work and the
government introducing it doesn't
believe it will work they simply want to
tell those people including farage's uh
uh uh voters that actually it's safe to
come back to them and vote for them it
won't actually have any effect on
immigration actually I'm pretty sure
that Nigel farage will say the same
thing in a moment's time but actually
when he does it will be self-serving
except when I do it's not
okay time is very updated you're going
to have to I just want to finish with
what lord ashof said at the end of his
report because it struck me as being
true the reason why immigration has
become so important he said people's
concerns about immigration are of a
bigger set of anxieties they see the
pace of change continuing and even
accelerating and they know Britain in 20
years will look different from the
Britain of today it was very interesting
that all David's examples about major
change actually did not involve
immigration at all as it happens and
they know Britain in 20 years will look
different from the Britain of today let
alone that of 20 years ago some welcome
that many are ambivalent and others are
scared in the end migration is
inseparable from global economic
conditions governments appear as
powerless to manage the first as to deal
with the consequences of the second what
this motion invites you to do is to see
the benefit of immigration but not join
with those who say that somehow or other
the problem of change is mostly a
problem of immigration it is not it is a
problem of a people adapting to the new
and we don't help them to do it by
pointing the finger of blame at people
actually who are not responsible vote
for the
motion thank you
thank you very much our final speaker is
the white male middle-aged former stock
broker who says he wants to change the
face of British politics he is of course
the you'll get there in the end he is of
course the leader of the UK independence
party ukip which calls for an end to
mass what it calls Mass uncontrolled
immigration please welcome the last
speaker against the motion Nigel
farage well Jonathan thank you and good
evening what you forgot to say was and
the descendant of political refugees
because my forbears were French and they
were Protestant and they were Hugo and
rather than be burnt at the stake they
came to this country and it's
interesting that if you think of all the
countries in Europe Europe the one that
has been the most open the one that has
been the most welcoming whether it was
to the Hugo whether it was to two big
migrations of Jews whether it was to the
Uganda Asians that Arman threatened to
kill this country has been the most open
and has been the most welcoming and yet
just 10 years ago when I stood up and
said that I thought it was the height of
irresponsibility to open our doors
unconditionally to eight former
communist countries in Eastern Europe I
was H down and abused and called all the
names under the sun um and and and told
effectively that it wasn't even
respectable to have a debate about
immigration in this country well that
has changed and that's the most
important thing tonight is we are
actually talking about this
subject and I'm not against
immigration but I'm against uncontrolled
immigration we need to control
immigration we need to choose the people
that are coming to live work and settle
in in this country and and and not one
of us on our side is against immigration
or against immigrants you know there's
no doubt the food is better uh no
question about it um you know I'm just
about old enough to remember how
appalling food was even in London so
that's good and a bit of diversity in
life particularly in our cities is fun
and it's good but we must think about
this in terms of it being a numbers game
and we need to think about this with
some sense of historic iCal context you
know I mentioned the Uganda Asians when
they came there was a massive National
debate could this country cope with the
sheer number of people and in the end
the decision was taken uh that whether
we could cope or not morally we had an
absolute duty to help those people and
27,000 people came from Uganda um and
have all done phenomenally well and in
fact if you think back to you know Ken
talked about the 1950s and about win
rush and about the beginning of
Caribbean immigration if you look at the
way we handled immigration postwar 30 to
50,000 people a year came and settled in
this country consistently over half a
century until of course that is Mr Blair
got into
office and decided that he wanted to rub
the noses of the right in diversity and
started to pursue an immigration policy
on a scale that we've never seen before
added to which with EU membership in
2004 we open the doors yet further you
know David blunkett told us an extra
13,000 would come a year from Eastern
Europe and 800,000 came in the first two
years in the whole history of these
islands we have never seen migration on
the scale that we've seen in the last 15
years uh from from 30 to 50,000 a year
it is now 450 to 500 ,000 people a year
that are coming into this country it's a
minimum net 4 million increase since
1997 so it's very important to get a
handle on it now look I I completely
understand that for the rich for people
living in Kensington this is
marvelous it's cheaper chauffers it's
cheaper
nannies and cheaper gardeners in the
cotsworld where you go at the weekends I
mean all of that's lovely and I totally
understand that if you're a big employer
that it's a good thing because it means
cheaper labor and it's had a positive
effect on wage inflation in this country
all of that in economic terms is totally
undeniable but what is also undeniable
despite the claims of the other side is
that we have had an overs Supply in the
unskilled labor market in this country
since
2005 and as a direct result of that
youth unemployment in Britain has gone
from 600,000 in 2005 to over a million
today and it is direct and it is causal
and yes I know there are problems with
British with with British education and
I accept that but David you know not all
these youngsters are illiterate gang
members and I really get upset with this
myth that Blair started and that all the
national newspapers now push that almost
all young British people are lazy and
useless I can tell you in the earlier
part of this year I spent a fortnite
night touring the length and breadth of
England in the in the run up to the
county elections and everywhere I went I
found desperate young people really
wanting to get work but now feeling
discriminated against in their own
country the first person I met that that
made me realize this was a 16-year-old
girl in Petra who told me she couldn't
get a job at the local packing Factory
because she couldn't speak Polish and if
you now in many of those Eastern
counties wanted to go and get the jobs
picking cauliflowers or cabbages or
fruit in season you've got no chance
because the gang Masters are in control
and it's polls and lithuanians and
perhaps even Portuguese that get the
jobs we have through irresponsible Open
Door immigration on a scale never seen
in Britain before effectively betrayed
workingclass people in this country and
it's led to great social division uh in
in in many parts of the country we're
now divided by language I don't think
it's a good thing that 82% of primary
school children in newm come from
families in which English is not the
first language that's not uniting people
that's not bringing people together
that's actually dividing people and all
over this country not just in the big
cities but actually uh in the market
towns everywhere I've seen it I get the
feeling that this country is less happy
with itself less at ease and we have
growing social tension now we intend of
course to continue with this process
because we intend next year on the 1st
of January to open our doors
unconditionally to two countries that
are even poorer to two countries that
sadly have not recovered from communism
to two countries that have within them a
completely dispossessed discriminated
against group um of people the Roma
numbering between four and five million
um and I think
really why I'm urging you to vote
against this motion is that it is
irresponsible to have an open door not
to have some degree of control and it's
something that is clearly not wanted in
this country you David said 60% well
whether it's 60 or 70 or 80 or whatever
it is the overwhelming majority of
people in Britain want us to have some
degree of control and that doesn't mean
we don't want any immigration of course
we do we want many of the brightest and
the best coming into this country
especially into London and into our
wealth creating industries of course we
want people of course I want us to have
an immigration policy based very much on
the one that the Australians have let's
have control let's get good people let's
get people that want to integrate and
will integrate but you cannot support a
motion that says that high which means
basically no control over immigration is
a good thing for Britain and while the
use of the word fear uh in the motion
perhaps is pushing it a bit we should at
least I would suggest be deeply
concerned that Brit successive British
governments the Coalition following on
from labor have learned nothing from the
lessons of the past we do not need
massive oversupply in the unskilled
labor market in this country we need to
get a grip and Take Back Control of our
borders properly thank
[Applause]
you
thank you thank
[Applause]
you thank you very much that brings uh
that was the last of the formal speeches
for and against the motion it's going to
be your turn next before we get to that
before we open up the I want to uh give
you the result of the vote that you the
votes you cast as you came uh into the
Hall here and uh all to play for really
absolutely split I would say evenly
before the debate 30% % of you were for
the motion the believed in other words
yes let them come 30% of you just under
a third said that against that motion in
other words don't let them all come uh
just over a third at
37% and then the don't knows the group
that are absolutely crucial to be and
all to be played for exactly onethird
33% of you would don't knows so they're
the group that all of our speakers here
are working hard to Target the swing
voters as it were and uh we'll compare
again those numbers once you vote uh at
the end so let's now open uh up to
questions contributions Etc I see a hand
here there we have people with
microphones I'm going to take these in a
group so if the microphone can come here
and have we got somebody there we'll do
those first too and uh where is there a
microphone over there yes have you got a
microphone so if you get it to that hand
nearest you okay so we'll start with
you yeah thank you I think it needs to
be made clear that micro and have no
recourse to public funds it's very
clearly stamped in their passport which
makes me wonder what how how the panel
thinks when does someone stop being a
migrant do they have to have been living
here for a certain number of years is it
when you're naturalized do you have to
have been born here Do you parents have
to be born here um just a comment to
Harriet on her example of swagger in the
poles briefly
yeah a Polish person earning the same
amount as a as Swagger seems to have
enough money to pay for their lifestyle
in the UK as well as send money home for
a four-bedroom house and the kids school
fees and pay council tax yes wagger
doesn't have enough money to pay council
tax and just a final comment on
Australia in terms of family immigration
rules Australia has no income
requirement for its citizens and
residents to bring in a spouse unlike
the 18,600 which we have here they also
encourage the adult dependent relatives
to come in at a younger age when they're
healthier in order to encourage
integration I'm going to have to cut
because otherwise if everybody speaks as
long as you do we we won't get be able
to leave yeah let's hear from you thank
you though I've got a note of the
question and the points yeah the nasty
right- Wingers like Nigel farage would
like to restrict the rights of fantastic
salvation women like Malala from coming
to this country the nasty left wiers are
are happy for fantastic South Asian
girls like Malala to be aborted would
these left Wingers be willing to clearly
state that not only are they willing for
South Asian women to live in this
country but to live okay I feel you've
slightly taken this into a different
territory that issue that issue has been
debated by intelligence squ and will be
again but we're probably not the one for
tonight who's got the mic for in there
yeah uh would David aranovich be happy
to share with us his views on the
correlation between numbers coming in
and the prospects for integration
assimilation but particularly any link
that he could see see between numbers
and what I would think is a simulation I
hope he accepts that concept thank you
are you clear on what he's asking there
because I'm wonder if we just need to
press you say what would be an
acceptable number is that what you're
asking yes how easy would I mean is
there a link between how easy it is for
immigrants coming into this country to
become part of the whole part of we and
the numbers it's an old question it's a
numbers question as far said it is a
numbers game is there somebody with has
a microphone nearby here okay one there
I'm going to just get four in now yeah a
question for the uh speakers against the
motion I just wanted to know
how they would address the pension
underfunding problem that this country
faces in uh both private Enterprises and
uh for public prospective retirees
without the benefits of mass immigration
right how will there be enough money to
pay for people's pensions without IM
thank you I know there's lots of hands
I'm only going to take clusters of three
or four uh and then and but I will come
back so hands down while we get some
answers to those questions um what about
the David rovic to you in a way is there
any limit or are the numbers Limitless
that you think Britain can absorb and
can be yeah absorbed into the country no
I
don't you know I don't think that you
can say that they're Limitless but what
I'm saying what I think is that we'
haven't reached the limits but I that
the question that was being asked really
was uh goes back to this question of the
speed with which people come in uh and
the problems of integration simulation
and so on um and if we look at the bus
of things which surround that let's say
the debate about forced marriages not
arranged marriages forced marriages um
or let's say the wearing of the nicab
and so on we or or the business of
people being sent back to Pakistan girls
being sent back to Pakistan without
finishing their education it is clear
that in some what we call migrant
communities there are significant
problems of transition and there still
continue to be significant problems of
transition and each time we come up
against that we have to try and deal
with it it's equally clear that amongst
other uh uh migrant communities there
are nearly no problems of transition so
it makes it very difficult and I think
well for instance it's very difficult I
think to argue that you can tell by
walking down the street and by
conversation uh walking down the street
unless you hear the conversation
what is a young pole and what is uh
somebody who was born in you know you
you you not now back into the visible
minority territory that you condemn no
no no I I I I I I have not yet heard of
of Polish Catholics wearing the nicab
for instance um uh and so and so nor nor
do I think is that that kind of density
or of Separation that you get in the
northern mil towns in particular where
you get very significant problems of
community separation all I'm saying is
that for the vast majority of migrants
don't fit into the categories that seem
to have enormous difficulties with
integration and assimilation okay um
Nigel farage I'm going to make this
quite quick because I want to get more
people in uh you were the one who
mentioned Australia and the questioner
said that there is actually no income uh
requirement in Australia and so would
you be happy with that for example well
I mean you can't go to Australia if you
have a serious criminal record you can't
go to Australia not the very beginning
it was rather
different they rather reversed that they
rather reversed
that that's rather new yeah you know yes
it used to be mandatory of course but um
you can't go to Australia if You' got a
life-threatening disease uh you have to
be basically under the age of 45 um and
you have to have some skill or trade of
some kind to bring um and if you listen
to successive Australian Prime Ministers
they're very very clear they couldn't
care less where you come from what your
religion is what your color is but when
you come here you become part of the
Australian dream and I would argue that
is a good sensible model for us to think
about some new immigration rules once
we've got once we've got back control of
our borders you mentioned
the no she was talking about the rule
for spouses but you just mentioned
life-threatening diseases is that
something you think is a danger here
with immigrants coming here they bring
in diseases it's very interesting the
NHS debate on this is very interesting
because the argument always gets put oh
well of course if we didn't have migrant
workers uh you know the hospitals
couldn't possibly run uh but we're
beginning to hear the counterargument
slowly but surely that actually many
many billions of pounds a year are being
used effectively to treat people who are
coming here for the reasons of Health
tourism and I think well we don't know
David and that's the point and and and
you know it's exactly the same it's
exactly the same you know it's billions
you don't much it is it's exactly the
same as the government made it up as the
government admitted as the government
admitted two days ago you know part of
the r that's been going on you know what
is the cost cost of social benefits to
Eastern Europeans in this country and
the government doesn't have any figures
and the NHS doesn't have any figures so
it's quite difficult for us to get a
handle on this surely well well we don't
do that you see cuz we try and deal
objectively in fact um and that's the
whole point about about the immigration
debate that the facts are that that more
people settled in this country in 2010
than came between 1066 and and
1950 and that giv you some idea of what
of what we're talking about we've got
the there's so many people that want to
come in please don't try and come back
in again um to there were two questions
uh that were directed at this side of
the table so David goodart do you want
to just address this point about how
well we pay our pensions dependence uh
if we don't have immigrants in the
workforce and do it briefly you can and
then I'm going to take another round um
I I I do first of all though just want
to come back on um David aronovich is
rather sort of snide implication that I
I was uneasy about the ratio nature of
the change in this country um race has
not been Central to debate tonight it is
not Central to the to National debate
now as it was in the postcolonial period
in the 1950s 60s and 7s the point is in
1950 Britain was almost entirely white
so the the measurement of demographic
change is partly the measurement of the
different different ethnic composition
of the country I mean if you're saying
that it's not reasonable to talk about
these changes long you you're put
pushing the debate back and I'm as
everybody on your side seems to be in
the 1980s you're having a debate about
whether immigration is a good thing or a
bad thing we're not having a debate
we're we're having a debate here about
whether High immigration should be
happening or not and one of the reasons
one of the really poor reasons for
having very high levels of immigration
is pension point but all the serious
economists have long since rejected this
idea because you get on to a treadmill I
mean unless you want the the population
of Britain in 1900 was 30 million the
population of Britain in 2000 was about
60 million if you want the age structure
remain the same the population of
Britain at the end of this Century will
have to be 120 million now people who
want the age structure to say say well
we got to have lots and lots of
immigrants we have that we get onto this
treadmill of population increase and the
point is you know that the immigrants
get old too they quite quickly Converge
on the family size of the existing
population it really is no answer at all
okay because you're I'm going to come
back to all of you so don't worry about
that you've got a questioner there and I
know lots of people to get in so I'll
try and get as many of you as you can
and if you're brief that will help me
yeah hi um my question goes out to
whoever is in charge of the procurement
of Talking Heads uh why is it that in a
debate on immigration there are no
immigrants but rather someone who can
trace his immigration his family history
back to the henaut or someone with a
friend in South
London um okay
um if it's thank you um I'll speak on
behalf of the organizers here just on
that very specific point while of course
we have the most Stellar panel we could
ever have dreamed of the in organizers
do tell me they did try indeed to get an
exactly the speaker and they approach
several people they approach several
people and they did actually decline the
invitation so that point was thought of
let's hear the question from you
then hello my name is suan hanock um it
seems to me that the entire panel agrees
that the real problem is poor education
and the fact that all these terrible
immigrants are simply better now if you
believe in a free economy and free
markets why don't you just make your
product better and then you don't have
anything to fear okay thank you thank
you um some somebody has got the
microphone next there yeah um the whole
debate tonight seems to have been a
little one-sided in the sense that um
we've only talked about people coming
into this country and it's effectively a
debate about protectionism now can you
imagine having a debate about trade
where we say we would really like to
export to every country in the world but
we won't let them import anything here
and so the other side of this debate is
if we want to close down our borders we
will have to accept that we will not be
able to work or live in any other
country as British people because I
can't imagine that the entire world will
keep open their borders for us to move
to if we want to put controls in place
in the other direction and so the the
population of Brit British people living
in France and Spain but also in North
America and many other places will be
dramatically affected by these kind of
changes thank you that's a sharp
question I'll make sure it comes out I'm
also aware by the way that so far the
two questions we've got have been
directed at this end of the table so if
you do have a question that is
challenging the side for the motion that
will be good so maybe keep your hand up
for that but we you've got the
microphone here I hope young woman who
spoke to us before told us of her
confidence speaking before a big
audience here we go um I have a question
for and against maybe just do the one
for because we're short of time yeah um
I was going to say that since one of the
speakers said that London's population
is drastically changing every five years
don't you think that London will lose
its ability to provide people with like
a communal sense of existence there okay
and and you because you think that's a
threat if it keeps churning it will lose
that sense of community yes thank you
okay and then there's a lady here who
should have the microphone being brought
to her I you did have your hand before
yeah you've got it okay off you go yes
hi this is for either side really but um
I'm an American I came here three years
ago to get a master's degree and I
stayed here on a poststudy work visa
which allowed people who got a degree
here to stay for two years and spend
some time in society working and
contributing back while I was on that
Visa this debate about numbers and
focusing on numbers really came to the
four and they canel the poststudy work
visa program it was one of the first
ones to go so I'm just wondering if
anyone has any thoughts about making
this an issue about net migration and
numbers and whether that has effects on
certain non-eu migrants or groups of
migrants that might be easier to
regulate than than others because that
your fear is that might be deterring
people like you who want to come here to
study Etc absolutely or people who have
studied and want to stay okay um thank
you I know there's more people who want
to get in if we have time I'm going to
do another round and if I can even get
in another one after that I will but
let's put these questions to you why
don't we start with you Susie Sims this
um point about the churn the questioner
asked you know if the population in
London just take London as an example is
going through that kind of turn and up
and churn and upheaval how do you
maintain the kind of sense of community
in a city as big as this if the
population is moving as much as it is I
see why that appears to be a worry but
one of the things I would do is just
point out at how many other periods in
the past if we take a long enough view
this has happened you know because this
nonsense about talking about levels of
numbers it really breaks my heart we
just have to think in terms of
percentages when we worry about
absorption and change and we're talking
about 1% of the population a year it's
1% coming in it doesn't matter across
the whole country but in an area of huge
immigration like London global global
cities like London like Paris like
Berlin like New York are cities that are
Chang changing faster that's the world
that we live in that's a global world
you want to be in cities that are
attracting people to come in and you
want to hold the good people when they
do come and we just need to find ways in
which we build on small communities that
give people a sense of Engagement with
where they live but also recognizing
that they're part of a big city and a
big world that's changing very fast okay
Harry Sergeant I want to put to you the
the point because it relates in a way to
the stories you were telling about uh
the the teenage gang that you worked
with for your book this idea that the
question is said Well if you know if you
believe in free markets and the
product's not good enough the product in
this case being workers uh who are
British born then you've just got to
make the product better so they can
compete and it picks up the challenge
David aronovich said you know we used to
people on the right used to say
competition was great now you seem to be
arguing the comp you know if
competition's too strong people would
give up so what's your response to that
me well I I say yes I mean I mean my I'm
passionately Keen that the education
that these young men are just having
their lives wasted and that of course
we've got to give them um the skills and
the motivation that the immigrants have
and I um rather like Nigel have you know
been around the country and interviewed
large numbers of these young people and
have been completely brokenhearted here
they're bright they're ambitious but
they just simply have not g been given
the very basic tools to compete so I
agree that that is quite unfair I also
um I think picking up that there was a
question about this kind of free market
which I thought was a great question um
and you know I'm all for free markets
but then you've got to at the same time
have a kind of level market and the
moment the sort of um the the the the
the the push and the pull is is so very
different I mean um how would you make
the market level well the minimum wage I
mean just to give an example um the
minimum wage here is is is four times um
the average wage in Poland and nine
times in Romania so it's rather like me
suddenly hearing that there's an EU
country that was offering four times our
average wage our average wage is around
about
26,000 was offering four times our
average wage for for to do sort of um
cleaning or washing or whatever okay I
mean I would immediately get my daughter
who is the uh young um same agees
immigrants you know ambitious and
skilled like them I say look you can go
put her on a plane and send her off in
all seriousness why why because I mean
it's the equivalent I'm just trying to
give it's the equivalent of £100,000 for
us but well that leads to then the other
question which was this is a two-way
street and if we close the borders so
that people can't come in then our
British citizens can't go out to the
rest of the world and work there
farage what about that because British
workers are all over the world
entrepreneurs in America and Australia
free trade deal two Street surely free
trade deals are never accompanied by
total Open Door free flows of people who
can go and live work and settle
somewhere free trade deals nearly always
have with them you know sensible
reciprocal work permit schemes and there
is an encouragement of people working in
each other's countries and I sometimes
think what we've gone wrong with this is
we've forgotten what work permits are
because we've sort of we we we've done
away with that people don't come here to
work so much now they come here actually
to settle and to use the Health Service
and if they need to claim benefit or put
their kids through primary school so
let's think a little bit more perhaps
about work permits and you know I'll
tell you this on this point about free
trade even Milton fredman the high
priest of free markets even fredman who
believed in the free flow of goods
capital and services even fredman never
believed in the free flow of people
especially between rich and poor country
thank you here's what we're going to do
I'm going to get squeezing these last
few and then we're going to have closing
speeches here while you vote so these
last three need to be really brief
gentleman here and then we're going to
get the microphone to the young man
there and in between we're going to go
to the lady who's got the microphone
over there and that's going to be all
I'm afraid yeah good both sides explain
how they're going to pay for their
respective policies housing if it's
unlimited who's going to pay if you're
going to restrict how are you going to
pay to improve the infrastructure at a
time of shortages of money thank you if
we can get this microphone back to the
very young man in a white shirt there
keep your hand up yeah that's it so we
can know where to get to and then the
lady is got the microphone here yeah yes
oh okay
so it's no not the rest of you just the
the young person there who has a hand up
there we go good wait just wait because
we're going to hear from the lady here
yeah so we heard two arguments one that
it isn't about race and two that it is
about class um firstly on the point
about it being about class and saying
that um the it is the working class that
have to fear the immigrants I think the
working class have to fear
us and the politicians because for the
past 20 years we have not put in the
public policy to give them the chance to
be able to compete and secondly the
point you make about London being 45%
white British I'd like to point out that
I am very British I may not be white but
I'm very British and therefore um
statements like that really don't help
these type of debates okay thank
you thank you and then this is going to
be the last contribution from the floor
yeah hi um this is a question um um for
the opposition but I suppose could be
commented on by the proposition as well
and there seems to be inconsistency in
your um speeches first David you say how
there's this like terrible brain drain
in which um all the intelligent people
from the um countries which people are
immigrating from IAD of coming here and
sad of taking all the talent away and we
should rather keep the um intelligent
and educated people there and then we
hear from n of Rage that we should
actually be handpicking our people so we
only get the bright and intelligent
people who going to contribute to our
economy which if either of you are
actually right ah very okay so you
sented a contradiction on that side
thank you for that here's where we've
got to the moment where you are all
going to vote people will be moving
around among you uh with ballot boxes if
you are voting for the motion in other
words you are believe immigrants can
come let them come you're voting with
this team over here with Susie Ken and
David tear off the bit that says four
and and if you are against you're with
Nigel Harret and
David please plop the bit that says
against keep sh we still going to have
speeches so I need you to keep the
volume down if you want to abstain you
put the entire card in the box the whole
card in the box now keep the volume you
don't need this is It's a silent ballot
as well as a secret ballot sh you need
to keep the volume level low because we
now have summing up speeches which you
may hear as you uh come come to finalize
your vote we're going to do this in
reverse order just 2 minutes each cuz we
are running against the clock and I'm
going to start with in reverse order so
Nigel farage let's start with you what
and it closing remarks and perhaps pick
up the questioner there who said he
spotted a contradiction some saying pick
the best and the brightest others saying
it's because the best and the brightest
are coming they're denying jobs to our
young people here so Nigel farage you
can do it at the table here actually
thank you the argument wasn't the
argument wasn't that the argument was we
do not need to have a massive oversupply
of the unskilled labor market Market of
course we want good skilled people
innovators wealth creators to come to
our country even though we accept it
will be to the detriment of other
countries uh Jonathan thank you uh for
the conduct of this evening I want to
make one very simple point to you ladies
and gentlemen this is a numbers game
just think about the history of this
country think about how we've managed
migration think about how we've proudly
uh given Refuge to those fleeing in fear
of their lives and add up all of those
numbers and they are as nothing compared
to what has happened in the last 15
years we have seen if we if we get out
of the wealthier parts of London and go
to the poorer bits of London or get or
get out into the rest of the country um
I think that the proposes of this motion
have got slightly Rose tinted spectacles
something very dramatic has happened in
the course of the last 15 years a
country that was generally very much at
ease with itself is now I found in many
parts of the country incredibly tense we
have Division and growing enties in our
Market towns and cities that I never
thought we'd see and I don't want to see
we already have a massive social problem
in integrating the 4 million people that
have come here in the last 15 years the
last thing we need to do is to carry on
with a policy of Open Door irresponsible
uncontrolled immigration this motion is
in itself irresponsible nobody nobody
sensibly could say that we shouldn't
have some degree of control over this
issue we can argue then whether it's a
net 80,000 a year or 50,000 a year or
whatever it is but at least then we
would be in control um I thought 50,000
was nearer the mark but either way we
need to be in control of it we need to
be selective it is irresponsible and we
are betraying our workingclass
communities in this country and many as
Harriet mentioned of our ethnic
minorities feel betrayed by what has
happened since 1997 and indeed they have
and so I urge you to vote for common
sense and to oppose this motion thank
you very
much thank
you so if you if you agree with Nigel
farage remember you're slipping in the
piece of a that says against our next
person to sum up uh in state you can do
it from here uh David aronovich two
minutes to you thank you um I can't help
wondering that when Nigel's Hugo
ancestors came over there was n the
leader of a kind of small party around
let's call him wat farage um leading a
campaign to have them sent back on the
basis either that they had
life-threatening illnesses the pox or
French warts or something like that um
or that they were overc competing with
Smithfield Weavers Etc who were going to
be out of a job and not actually being
able to tell you in the end which it was
that he was more scared of is just that
he wished they wouldn't come whichever
it was um in fact fact the scale of
immigration that we've seen is not
unprecedented David goodhart can only
get it to be unprecedented in his book
by treating the Irish immigration to
this country which was in percentage
terms far greater than the immigration
we've seen recently by treating as if it
was somehow indigenous immigration and
the Irish from V the Irish people from
Villages like skarin Etc uh in the 1840s
were as assimilable and as assimilated
to British community is from Brighton to
Liverpool um as uh as a British person
as an English person would have been as
English person would have the said
actually an awful lot of it happened
incredibly quickly David and it was a
very high level immigration as I said
you as I said you finessed it let alone
finessing internal migration from the
country to the towns which happened at a
far more significant scale I only say
that to say that times of great change
see people on the move and what we're
very good at if we allow it to happen
happen is reconstructing communities and
creating new communities and you know
what in answer the question that
happened that's exactly what has happen
in London communities are not just
people who are look the same and exist
speak exactly the same languages when
they start they are much more mobile
than that they are communities of
Interest people with small children meet
each other each other outside schools
and discover that they have things in
common with each other that's how
communities are created and they can be
created by all kinds of people in
including immigrants and in London this
incredibly successful Capital as Ken
said they have been uh created and to
huge success success in other words Mass
migration certainly in this capital and
I think in the country has been a great
success and we have nothing to fear from
it thank you
um thank you very much indeed and uh I
go next to somebody against the motion
and who the next person will be I think
is going to be David no in rever har now
I'm so sorry so Harr it is you who's up
and you've got two minutes uh and
particularly I wonder if you could
address that question that came at the
end which was uh about for example this
this worry that people have uh about how
long it would take for somebody to count
how long one of the very first questions
that was asked about how long it takes
to assimilate so let's well I mean we've
had some brilliant um arguments from the
other side but I find that their
arguments lack logic and they lack heart
I mean what really puzzles me is they
seem to love immigrants when they're
just over there somewhere or just on
their way here and all just arrived but
once they've stay here once they have
children here they this this other side
just seem to don't forget about them or
not like them I mean
um
I mean David David aronovich on his in
his blog uh describes um some of the
people that I know as you know festering
and littering the streets um which I
find actually quite obnoxious but it's
once they've been here for a generation
he feels that he can say that about them
um which doesn't make any sense to me at
all I mean what does he think is going
to happen when these polls for example
when they their children then go through
our state education system I mean are
they going to be they're going to be as
sort of unmotivated and unskilled as the
people now that he dismisses us
littering our streets I mean I have a
friend who works in a pupil referral
unit and they already this this is a a
school a unit where children who have
been really bad and been kicked out of
every possible School are sent they
already have three polls in that pupil
referral unit so you know why do you
just lose interest in immigrants when
they're the second
generation okay I you got 25 30 seconds
so just okay I'm just saying I think
that migration is allowing us to duck
out from the really serious thing that
is facing issue that's facing Us in this
company country which is lack of social
mobility and we are simply not not doing
anything about it because we can have
immigrants coming in what we should be
doing is is is trying to make our own
people as skilled and as motivated okay
thank you very much that's your closing
argument thank
you um Ken Livingston it's your chance
to sum up and I just want you to pick up
one question we didn't get an answer for
somebody asked about the housing it was
you particularly talk about housing
who's going to pay for it they said so
if you can pick that two minutes to you
I've been a manager for 40 years and
every budget I produced has been
balanced on Revenue uh and I think there
only been about five or six National
budgets so that's why a we have the debt
problem we have not just the banking
crisis Western politicians have always
borrowed a when there's recession as
kan's advis they never set to the next
chapter which say when You' got a boom
you pay it back and that's an emic
problem so I always prod balance budget
so I always had the freedom to borrow
money off the bond markets subdue things
like the London overground I and that's
the key difference now the way in which
we could actually build housing without
borrowing is say to the bloody Bank of
England instead of doing this quantitive
easing
375 billion pounds which just flowed
into the International Financial system
produce the money to build the homes the
bank of lingwood would be the owner
they'd be managed by local authorities
it's not increasing debt it's increasing
the asset base of the country then just
finally on this is is you what how we
Define when someone becomes British or
whatever what I like about being British
is there are no rules about being bloody
British you can live exactly whatever
mad way you want as you don't break the
law unlike France with some fairly rigid
and unpleasant rules and if I think
about it if you I represented sto Newton
with the largest Orthodox Jewish
Community I IM anywhere in Europe a have
we been diminished because they've
retained much of their culture where
other Jews have virtually lost I mean I
know Jews who who've never got involved
in their religion at all I and each
person who comes here makes their own
choice I mean 20 years down the road
there will be people of Muslim origin
who've never read the Quran so the
others still devoutly following it we
aren't diminished by that diversity I
believe we're strengthened by it and
just finally I was really struck by I
Harriet's opening speech was very
similar to mine she identified a problem
that has hit the working class there's
two answers though was that caused by a
immigration or was it caused by the
failed neoliberal experiment of Thatcher
and Reagan hey because I'm a guardian
reader you won't be surprised to
discover interesting chart this week
about how poorly Britain and America are
doing on the three Rs we're at the
bottom of that but we're the most
unequal of all the societies they were
looking at this is the tragedy we're in
a mess communities have been destroyed
DED because of the failure of our
economic policies not because someone
came here from abroad okay thank
you we hearing a little unpleasant chime
which I don't know what that quite
denotes but we'll perhaps find out we
going to wait a second this is the piece
of paper with the results which is
crucial um it's true now normally that's
a metaphor about what's happening to
immigration and our Society but it's
actually um maybe more literal um I want
to go next to our penultimate speaker uh
David goodart and I want you if you can
David to take up the point that somebody
did ask they said they are British
they're not white British but they're
British what does that have to do with
it she said and it's not helpful so
you're summing up um we have to remember
that the situation is not a static one
um to return to this guy Paul KY who I
mentioned in my opening remarks uh about
very influential and important
development economists his recent book
Exodus about why large scale immigration
does not help poor countries had at its
heart a a model um which describes why
immigration sorry imigration will be of
a rising scale over the next 100 150
years or so perhaps before the when the
world becomes more kind of evenly
developed then then immigration is going
to cease to become a big issue but for
the time being there are three things
that mean that it's going to remain a
huge issue and there are going to be
huge flows unless we have you know
responsible Fair restrictions in rich
countries one of them is the fact that
there's a huge income gap obviously
between poor countries and rich
countries reduced a little bit by China
and India but not very much his second
point was that there are now very large
diasporas in rich countries like ours
which reduced both the psychological and
economic cost of movement so I mean you
know it was much harder to to be a seek
Indian coming to South Hall in 1960 than
it is today thirdly there are many more
people in poor countries who actually
have the we with all the kind of mid
middling income people in poor countries
and huge proportions of them want to
move uh and I and you know who can blame
them but it creates this
hugely unevenly developed world where
that you know the the the most ambitious
and brightest people in the poor
countries come to the rich countries uh
they you know and and and in some cases
damage the interest of poor people in
rich countries let's have more even
development of the world that'll be
fairer for everybody um when when a
country is changing its its immigration
policy as ours is I'm I'm a labor
supporter but I think the government is
broadly speaking getting it right there
are bound to be mistakes they're bound
to there are bound to be unfairnesses uh
you know you're you're moving from one
whole system to another um but I mean I
mean David R MIT I mean talks about um I
mean the whole point about the labor
party was about at least limiting
competition in the in the labor market I
mean that sort of was what it was for
and now the idea is to have not not only
no um no protection at all and you know
just you know competing with people from
all sorts of other countries who have
you know who who are coming from have
much lower wage expectations and so on
we've got to have some degree of fellow
citizen favoritism including all
citizens of whatever race or religious
background I mean of course I believe
that I mean it's just just basic um but
fellow citizen favoritism that that that
gives people a sense of common
citizenship and common Norms otherwise
we're not going to have a welfare state
in 30 or 40 years time okay um Susie SS
you're are going to be our final speaker
thank
you we we do we do now have the results
so if you can confine this to really a
very brief intervention from you minute
or two maximum that would be great and
off you go sus times well I want to know
where this warehouses where we're
putting our weakest performers cuz I
think I've got a couple of candidates
um they're not very good at sums not
very good at
numbers I'm not going to bother trying
to teach David goodart economics because
better people than me have been trying
over the past year or two uh to teach
him about the lump of Labor f Y and uh
he's not got it yet and I don't suppose
he's going to he's also not very good at
reading um Paul kier's book it's not a
great book he's he's a terrific
Economist and he knows an enormous
amount about poor countries um but he
doesn't say the things that David says
he says we have to really worry about
accelerating not current levels
accelerating levels of uh losses of
people
permanently from very poor countries
that's a legitimate worry and a
legitimate concern you don't solve it
however by putting up barriers and
preventing them coming you solve it by
and he's right for once um on more equal
distribution between rich and poor
countries I'd like Nigel farage to have
the guts to come down and see me in 19
prinet Street the Museum of immigration
uh it's in the middle of Brick Lane uh
where I spend most of my life so I know
quite a lot about the people he claims
that we don't know anything about uh he
might learn something about past
immigration instead of telling these
fairy stories about how wonderful and
lovely and welcoming everything was in
the past um so if he'll come that would
be fantastic come and speak to some of
the people uh in Brick Lane I think the
key thing here is that some of the
issues that Harriet talked about are
Absolut abely desperately important they
really are they're at the core of what
we ought to care about as an equal
society that gives equal and fair
opportunities to everybody but we don't
do that by scapegoating immigration it's
not migrants that caused the class
system in this country it's not migrants
that caused social immobility and it's
not migrants that make it so hard for
these young people whom we failed to get
get jobs thank you very
much thank
you I want to thank Susie and all all
six speakers I think absolutely terrific
quality of debate tonight um the result
is fascinating and testament to the fact
that our Debaters on both sides
succeeded is the fact that the don't
knows began the evening at 33% fully a
third of everyone here and that figure
has shrunk to
2% which is very very
unusual and that I think is a tribute to
the uh the performances from our
speakers before the debate those for the
motion who did indeed believe let them
come uh was stood at 30% and that has
rocketed upward to
47% those those against began the
evening at 37% in other words those on
this side of the argument who said don't
don't let them all come 37% and they too
have shot up to
51% it means that the motion has been
defeated this side is
Victorious thank you hold
on to a last thing left I want to remind
you all crucial piece of information
that the bar upstairs will be open until
915 but for now please join me in
thanking our speakers Susie Sims Ken
Livingston David aronovich David goodard
Harris n faral thank
[Applause]
you